so I'm in a relationship right now uh
everything's going great and I'm
planning on proposing uh maybe in the
next two weeks I was in a relationship
previously before the one I'm in now and
I was engaged to the uh girl and she
gave me back the engagement ring oh
don't do it don't do
it I was thinking about just using that
ring does your girlfriend know about
this past engagement no oh boy okay
number one have that combo first oh no
no no no no no she knew I was in yeah
she knew I was engaged before yes she so
do you not think she's going to her
first question is going to be wait is
that the ring from I I know I just don't
want to spend extra money on it because
Chris Chris christop a different the
moment you slide that ring on her finger
her her finger will catch fire